Welcome aboard and thanks for flying with Delta.
Our first priority on every flight is safety.
So before we depart, I'll be giving a brief safety presentation.
Okay, be sure all carry-on items are securely stored in an overhead bin...
...and place smaller items under the seat in front of you...
...and ensure all aisles, exits and bulkhead areas are clear.
And ensure your mobile phones and electronic devices are turned off.
If you're seated at an emergency exit,...
...please review the responsibilities for emergency exit seating...
...on the back of the Safety Information Card, which is in your seat pocket.
Are you willing and able to assist with the operation of the exit if necessary?
Yes.
Not really.
If you are unable to perform these functions,...
...please let us know and we'd be happy to find you another seat.
Hey.
As we leave the gate, make sure your seatbelt is fastened.
To fasten, insert the metal tip into the buckle and adjust the strap...
...so it's low and tight across your lap.
To release the belt, just lift the top of the buckle.
Please remain seated with your seatbelt securely fastened...
..anytime the seatbelt sign is on,...
...and even if the sign is off,...
...please keep your seatbelt fastened in case we experience unexpected rough air.
For everyone's safety, federal regulations require all passengers...
...to comply with the posted placards and lighted information signs...
...located throughout the cabin, in addition to any crew member instructions.
Smoking is not allowed on any Delta flight,...
...and federal law prohibits...
...tampering with, disabling or destroying a restroom smoke detector.